[Applaudissements]
encore
puisque vous aimez ça je vais arrêter ça
c'est la punition
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
tu te rends compte tu te rends compte de
l'effectuer de l'effectuer
donc comme il y a pas beaucoup de
vêtements je pense que c'est plutôt toi
ah merci quand même tu t'appelles
comment Zara
oh là là
quand tu es avec ton Jules comment il
t'appelle
moi aussi
on se calme
tu meures combien tu mesures
maintenant c'est un peu plus
ils font les mêmes pour hommes non
pas tout de suite tout de suite mais un
peu plus tard
tu t'es fait opérer
au moins quatre opérations
pour arriver à ça
c'était pudique quand tu étais petite
mais tu sais quand tu as 13 ans 14 ans
ça commence à grossir
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
sexuellement
ton premier amour ton premier vrai amour
mon vrai amour le premier vrai amour un
vrai amour
[Musique]
j'habitais avec un mec quand j'avais 17
ans jusqu'à 19 ans moi j'étais amoureuse
mais je pense c'était pas vraiment de
l'amour en fait
et ton premier amant
premièrement sexuellement c'est 16 ans
du boulot quoi
on s'en fout
ça prend combien de temps pour tourner
un film porno ça dépend où tu tournes
parce que aux États-Unis ils vont des
vidéos déjà dans un jour une journée
ils ont cinq cinq dollars et puis la
comédie tout ça dans une journée une vie
et il y a des films que j'ai fait les
plus grands films sont en 5 jours puis
en Europe normalement ils tournent dans
une semaine plus au moins ils sont plus
lents en Europe
il est en plus grand budget alors
il peut faire beaucoup plus de comédie
aussi parce que le comédie ça prend
beaucoup plus de temps parce que pas
tous les comédiens qui fait le hard sont
sont des vrais comédiens en fait leur se
prend plus de temps pour faire un film
porno ça dépend aussi si tu as un
certain nom si tu as pas un certain
nombre
ça dépend quand j'ai commencé aux
États-Unis c'était
100 dollars par jour et c'était très
haute pour les États-Unis parce que
normalement c'est 800 dollars 1000
dollars c'est le maximum
combien de films
vraiment du plaisir dans un film hard
souvent c'est ça dépend si la scène est
agréable dans une [__] tu peux bouger il
n'y a pas de réalisateur qui fait avoir
tout le temps tu peux te concentrer
tu peux prendre ton plaisir ça dépend si
c'est une chaise comme ça
le plus grand aux États-Unis pour la loi
tu as besoin de chaque mois devant
tourner le film il te prend avec les
caméras avec les tests de sida qui était
négatif et puis
il vient pas des dents les mecs parce
que ils doivent ça pour les films et on
met les éponges spéciaux on prend tous
les précautions puis parce qu'on
travaille déjà sexuellement c'est pas
que des dehors de travail on va discuter
qu'on va à boîte on va aller porter qui
parce qu'on a plus envie quoi alors
c'est toujours dans la famille non ça
c'est des minuit le risque tu peux pas
dire il n'y a pas de risque il y a
toujours de risques mais c'est même tu
vas à boite tu oublies la préservatif ça
c'est une risque encore plus rare tu as
eu honte de faire ce travail
[Musique]
la première fois j'étais nerveuse mais
c'était plus pour la comédie parce que
j'avais jamais fait ça mais honte non tu
avais quel âge la première fois
[Musique]
et à l'époque tu le disais ou quand tu
rencontreras un garçon dans une boîte de
nuit tu lui disais le métier que tu
faisais
mais c'est drôle quand je suis commencé
à faire ce métier là j'avais plus envie
d'aller en boîte et aller à n'importe
qui il y a les gens quelquefois les amis
comme ça qui savaient le travail que je
faisais et puis ici
si ça se passe qu'on va à Lyon ensemble
ils avaient peur parce que moi elle aime
un grand star elle fait ça alors ça
marchait plus tu vois ils auront trop
peur ils avaient peur de pas oui c'est
ça
quand tu rencontres un garçon il disait
qu'est-ce que tu fais dans la vie tu lui
disais ce que tu faisais ça dépend qui
s'était parce que il y a quelques fois
que je savais avant si je vais dire ça
il me prend comme une fille très facile
et j'aime pas ça il était très
vulgairement alors quelquefois je disais
sûrement je fais de modèle je suis pas à
l'époque on était avec un Jules tu le
trompais genre de ton travail tu le
tromper ou non
à l'époque
quand j'adore le travail
peut-être avec les filles mais c'est pas
un concurrence
c'est pas pareil avec les filles
avec les filles c'est une petite
tromperie
à 20 ans quand tu as fait ton premier
film x
je suis contente alors j'ai acheté un
billet pour elle pour venir sur plateau
pour voir que c'était pas les drogues
les orgies et tout ça c'est une chose
professionnelle
et maintenant elle a ouvert une agence
moderne et tout ça et quand tu auras des
enfants tu leur diras
maman elle faisait des films X quand
je trouve pas assez c'est juste
m'expliquer mais s'il demande des choses
comme ça oui tranquillement j'ai fait le
porno comme ça
vous avez devant vous l'auteur l'auteur
de l'oeuvre la plus scandaleuse qui est
jamais existé le Market
connaissez-vous mes œuvres
tu connais que ça ah formidable
qu'est-ce que vous faites dans la vie
pour le plaisir de la chair la
diriez-vous d'une petite séance de fouet
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
encore
puisque vous aimez ça je vais arrêter ça
c'est la punition
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
le devoir m'appelle voilà je vais y
aller je vais y aller vous venez avec
moi mais moi il faut que je vous
dématérialisme maintenant est-ce que ça
fait mal pas vraiment non quel dommage
bon ben alors je vais y aller vous venez
chez Mademoiselle
oui vous avez raison c'est vrai je
m'ennuie je viens avec lui
vous auriez aimé mon cher ami Jean
embarque avec moi vous êtes un maître
scandaleux pervers et puis surtout
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
tube abonnez-vous et mettez un pouce
bleu